so actually I just left that as the
title because that's what I you know
said I was going to talk about but I
actually cut the actual tool out of this
talk so apologies that the Graham kind
of talked about an open problem session
last week I think if you were here so
I'm just going to talk about Theory
motivated by other people's data okay
right so this talk is thanks to
everybody for coming and for talking to
me and it's been great to talk to people
and dawid new people and thanks for
organizing and everything i'm going to
be talking about is stuff i've been
doing with graham ok so going to quickly
go over some biological motivational
examples so and I apologize to those of
you in bits of this before but I'm
trying to get it I'm going to try to get
to the new things quickly so one set of
fun to think about examples are the
blood disorders in humans that that are
thought to be around because they
provide some resistance to malaria you
know despite being bad for you sometimes
you know that's probably why we know
about them because there's there things
that are good for you in terms of
malaria if you're heterozygous usually
but also bad for you especially if your
home is the I guess and things like that
may be the most common is sickle cell
allele it's a single base pair change
that's present on four different
haplotypes across Africa and it kind of
looks like that right and another
example there's a whole bunch of alleles
that result in g6pd deficiency there's
like a hundred and thirty sorry there's
thirty four of them that are at you know
not just seeing a couple times and so
present at some frequency somewhere and
here's a really nice map from a recent
review showing how these alleles cluster
across space okay in this example
differs a lot from the previous one
because that one was a single base
mutation and here there's something like
130 or 150 maybe different base pairs
that you could get mutations at and
produce the this phenotype okay so
motivation is that that we're seeing
something to do with adaptation and
we've got some sort of clusters on a map
okay and then for another motivational
example sort of for the second half
comes from the desert in the southwest
of the US and northern Mexico where you
know it's desert so there's lots of
rocks and and the rocks are different
colors depending on where we where you
are in particular there's in a lot of
places really dark outcroppings of rocks
that are caused by like old lava flows
and for instance you can see one there
and I learned recently that you know I
like to use this slide to say that look
look how patchy you know this is there's
lots of patches of dark rock and
actually if you go to these places
that's not maybe the color you'd
actually see I learned recently but but
it's something like this so my
maladjusted back in the 30s noticed that
when you went collecting out here the
color of animals that you caught would
often you know it would often match the
substrate that that they were living on
like you'd be more likely to catch
darker mice or darker rabbits if you're
trapping on areas with dark rock then
than otherwise and they sort of observed
this in some like a dozen species and
and it's been observed you know at least
hypothesized in reptiles also and
Michael Nachman in Hopi Hoekstra looked
into one of these systems The Rock
pocket mouse here are two individuals of
the same species that were collected on
you know from different populations you
know this one dark and the other light
and so and they showed that at least
you know in this area there is a single
locus there's a single allele of large
effect segregating at the MCR one hour
locust that's providing a lot of this
that's causing most of the change in
color and so you have a picture where
there's this one allele that makes my
starker that is beneficial on dark in
dark areas and deleterious elsewhere
because you know if you don't match the
color the substrate then you get eaten
by owls more often and if you don't
believe that's a strong selective force
then look at this picture okay and this
is also sort of an interesting example
because they did further work and looked
at other you know dark volcanic outcrops
in other parts of the southwest and and
found that you know well the change and
in color it was you know charitable and
everything it wasn't being caused by the
same mc1r allele it's interesting
because mc1r has been responsible for
adaptive coloration changes and a whole
bunch of other taxa like including
things like lizards so we've got this
adaptive coloration change being shared
you know the same basis shared between
different species but then also not
between different populations of the
same species which is kind of
interesting okay so i think that's it
for that motivation okay so i'm trying
to think about the geography of
adaptation okay so you know when you're
looking at a species spread across a
landscape when do you get when you're
looking at species spread across a
landscape that's been prevent presented
with some evolutionary problem when do
you get you know the populations didn't
different part of the range different
parts of the range coming up with the
same answers to that evolutionary
question when and when you know and
maybe communicated by migration and when
do you
get different areas coming up with their
own answers okay and sort of how often
that happens to things happen tells us
something about well first it tells us
about you know what what fitness
landscapes look like right like if local
adaptation happens all the time and it's
very important then that means there's
not sort of a single adaptive peak but
there's many Peaks that depend on where
you are now it tells us about constraint
because if you know different regions
independently come up with the same
solution to an evolutionary problem then
that's pretty strong evidence that there
aren't very many possible solutions that
to that problem but but we can only say
that if we know that that the that they
were actually independent and of course
things like speciation right because the
something we know about speciation is
that lack of gene flow and
differentiation is important so the main
sort of summarizing quantity that I want
to get at in different models is sort of
what's the geographic resolution of
adaptation sort of over what scale do
you get different solutions to the same
problem for instance and so like you
know under what circumstances do
different regions share solutions or do
it independently and also it'd be really
nice to know like how can we expect to
tell which is happening you know like if
if there's been the same change in
different places how do we tell if that
was independent or not ok that's the
motivational slide um so the rest of the
talk i'm going to talk about a
homogeneous landscape and an apache
landscape and i almost at the last
minute reverse the order of these two
for one thing because some of you that
this is familiar to many of you and also
partly because you know it overlaps to
some degree with pictures that a lot of
other people you know like rick and
jasmine's talk for
students so I'll try to go through this
quickly and get to this part and I'm not
going to be I wanted to put in a slide
with references to everything that made
us think about this stuff and I only got
one set of authors in there mmm okay so
um okay so um for the first part just
want to think about a homogeneous
landscape so there's a continuous
species range you know with constant
population density the environment has
changed so that some set of alleles have
gone from being deleterious to
beneficial and you know we're thinking
of a large class of mutations that you
know I'll do pretty much the same thing
and so when you look at a simulation you
see the different precancerous clusters
I sorry i mean the the the different
adaptations occurring and spreading
right and right so I was going to make a
so I was going to make a joke that um
there I'm done okay no I was gonna make
a joke that this this had been a model
of cancer but since Rick and Jasmine did
actually a much more complicated model
like looking at the appearance of
subsequent subsequent mutations on this
then I quick switched it over to talking
about you know organisms on the
landscape but but that's not you know we
just draw cartoons & and they they did
much more serious things um but it means
that a lot of a lot of what I'm doing
should be maybe familiar ok so one thing
that we've added here is that in the
picture that we want to think about is
that some alleles are present at
standing variation and sort of to be
able to have a picture that makes sense
we want to have them at present as
deleterious standard variation and sort
of the way that we think about that is
that there's some point process of
little clusters of delat of mutants that
had been deleterious and then after the
environment changes become beneficial ok
so then V after the environment changes
these and any new mutations fix locally
or not you know they have to escape
demographic stochasticity with some
probability and this is sort of how I
encode that probability right and then
if they do they spread radially with
some speed the dispersal distance times
the square root of the beneficial
selection coefficient sorry I should
explain notation except it's on the next
slide yeah okay um so combining all
these things we've got we can put down
in sort of a space crosstime picture the
Poisson process of mutations so there's
some new ones and some ones present t
equals 0 is standing variation those are
different Poisson processes with
different rates and then we have to thin
them by the chance that they escape
demographics to castor this be and then
if they have appeared at some location
at a location that hasn't adapted yet
they spread locally and then ones that
appear in places that have already
adapted we don't care about because
they're neutral at that point ok so this
is the cartoon and it's all Poisson
processes so by drawing sort of inverse
cones and doing computations with
Poisson processes we can compute
whatever you want um ok so um the way
you know we wanted to find out to get
some expressions for sort of order of
magnitude on what spatial scale do you
see independent adaptations so one way
of quantifying that is is well you know
it's it's the width of these
matches and
so here's time and here in space and say
that some point here that a point here
in time and space has been adapted if
there was at least one successful
beneficial mutation somewhere in this
comb you know because then that one
would have spread to cover it okay so
you know by turning things around you
can argue that that a good summary of
the spatial scale of this process is the
the diameter of a one of these cones in
space-time in which you expect to find
one successful mutation okay so that's
that solves this equation in general
where lambda 0 is the density of
standing variants pi is 3.14 then that
is the influx of new successful
mutations and V is the rate at which the
wave spread okay and with no standing
variation you can write down a solution
more easily and sort of the main thing
that we want to get out of this I think
is that it depends pretty weekly and a
lot of the parameters you know this
power one-third in in two dimensions
anyways means that to change the spatial
scale of this by a factor of ten you
need to change the dispersal distance by
a factor of thousand and you have to
change the strength of the selection
coefficient so how adaptive the new
mutation is by a factor of a million
which is kind of surprising um so what
is this
yes as SB and you can also compute
things like how long do you have to wait
until most places have got the adaptive
mutation which is a good thing to
compute if you want to compare this to
get data to make sure that you're
getting reasonable numbers in the
proportion of these patches that that
happen from standing variation versus
new mutation okay so any questions about
this before I go plug in numbers yes
pralaya to coopers it just purely well
because its face cross time yeah you
know Chris take the relevant things you
know each individual time gen x a
generation is an opportunity for a
beneficial mutation repaired and so you
just have to wait until you get a chunk
of those the right sides it was a linear
habitat it would be the square root uh
yeah
that might explain it
it's good to be in theft okay so so if
we make up some numbers I mean if we get
some numbers from the literature for the
sickle cell case and plug them in now
what we want to compare things to is
sort of this pattern is you know
happening over scale of like a thousand
kilometers and if we plug in a couple of
different parameters for how deleterious
you want sickle cell to be in the
absence of malaria which you know this
isn't quite right because it's oh no
never mind that's ugly you get sort of
in both cases so this is the deleterious
selection coefficient before malaria
appeared you get numbers really close to
a thousand kilometers you know the right
answer kind of miraculously and even
though these are really close the
proportion that you expect to have come
from standing variations has changed a
lot so we get pretty much the same
picture but a little bit of a different
story for what happened and you know
this shouldn't be too surprising because
you know you wouldn't really expect to
be able to tell the difference between a
new mutation happening and standing
variant that was around and only a few
copies beforehand but this is how it
works out um and if we apply this to the
g6pd example here there's more variants
and so the you know sort of spatial
scale over which you see these is
smaller like 350 kilometers if you
divide the total area by the number of
variants and take the square root you
could plug in various answers various
estimates for SB so this is the
beneficial the advantage to having one
of these d6
the variants and the main difference is
that the mutation rate is you know well
maybe naively 150 times bigger because
the target is bigger right so that's we
observe and we get something that's on
the right order of magnitude that may be
a little bit small and a fair proportion
of them coming from standing variation
and you know we have feared like the
time that adaptation you expect
adaptation to take and and sort of these
are smaller than that which is the right
thing ok so this all sort of makes sense
and makes us feel good yeah what about
environmental heterogeneity um done that
disturb your calculation I mean um like
I would think like that this is not
actually flatten here's that you mean
like that it's not actually flat in here
is that what you mean for instance yeah
probably um yeah I mean you know really
I just only believe this in terms of an
order of magnitude calculation and
really we probably ought to put in you
know where long-distance dispersal I you
know with the when you get like Oscar is
talking about when we we did that for
the first case in in our paper like it
didn't make a huge difference you know
it changed the numbers we got out a
little bit for the typical length but
not not as much as you might think so I
think it's a lot more interesting think
about in this case you know um is you
know one aspect of this that we're
totally not modeling is what happens
when the different adaptations meet each
other right and that depends on how they
interact with each other like what
happens to people who have two different
g6pd mutations and I don't actually know
the answer to that but i think it
on which ones you have and also not all
these mutations have the same selection
coefficient some of them are much worse
than others yeah
spread into your easy to
yeah there'll be I mean the first thing
that happens is they all mix together
right and that's sort of and that's why
I sort of estimated the characteristic
length but just by dividing the total
area by the number of variants but the
weight at which you lose them due to
drift is is you know typically much
longer and yeah I didn't write that that
would be another good calculation I mean
maybe the right model here involves
these different variants that have some
complicated some complicated set of
fitness coefficients depending on if
you're homozygous or heterozygous and
better you in somewhere with malaria and
whether their variants are around and
you might have sort of turning over of
different ones through time it yeah the
business may be the first thing to do
getting back to the question about just
seemed to me the energy associated with
the intensity of say malaria differently
in different quite a bit
it's out and you get a pretty big
difference in scale picking on your sort
of assumptions selection coefficient
that's the deleterious selection
coefficient or that both of them but
that's I was just changing done so the
beneficial selection coefficient is
changing from 25 to point o 4 and I was
keeping the deleterious one fixed at
point one so I guess what it is have you
actually investigated whether whether if
there is some variation there's a bias
overall using your sort of global
approach to estimating the scale right
that you're using taking a whole area
you could say okay let's suppose that I
have a mixture when I get right get a
reasonable I don't get the mean or the
Rockets harmonic estimate or what word
what is the real extra little scale very
compositional okay right so heaven
genius across the landscape yeah well
they said one thing that I know about
that I guess is that if selection
coefficient changes across the landscape
and said it but you know what's it
establishes instead of you know
constancy wave you have a way that like
whose speed changes depending on where
it is and you can either wave your hands
and make the argument that still what
matters is it's sort of average speed
right you know the average speed ought
to determine the scale in which you see
things so it depends on how fine grain
the environmental variability is
you know I think it could but I mean I
wouldn't even know how to begin to I
guess it sounds like a lot of work to
try and start making a more realistic
model with that and it would be it would
be lots of fun this is interested in
whether the systematic bias that one
could get at in just a toy model
bringing advice well you're coming out
with an estimate of scale yeah and other
certainly soldiers those are just even
employ a mixture of those assumptions
you could see whether there has two is
systematically one way or the other when
the variance right so I think if if the
speed that we use is the right average
seed and I guess I don't know what kind
of message then you should get minutes
of the advice that I don't know what
kind of marriage last one so did you say
what triggers the change
by malaria which is about to happen to
an agriculture started having like
dishes for the water around so you have
a date but that comes in all across well
like malaria didn't you know but as far
as I understand we think that malaria
didn't use to be endemic everywhere and
then people started being around ditches
full of waters or more often so and then
I'm trying to understand these age
estimates are they going with some
historical event that can be independent
elated right so it's a curving four
people have estimated by a you know
counting number of mutations under by
haplotypes or something that's one of
the ways to pick up these that the
various g6pd alleles are between four
hundred forty and four hundred
generations and so sort of has a check
of computed under this model how long
should you expect like the whole
population to have some of these alleles
and depending on the weather its weak or
strong that should be seven or thirty
generations and if this was if these
numbers were much larger than those
numbers that would need we're not
fitting the model very well
are we supposed to be puzzled that
malaria has been around longer than
seven generations yeah 32 Joe what this
is second step like the population under
the under this model the population
would have been you know every most
everybody would have had a g6pd allele
within seven generations of the onset of
malaria that's what this number needs
and then since then it's had time you
know those illegals have had time to mix
up yeah I'm sorry I wasn't a great beard
um okay I'm gonna be funded next right
now um okay so back to the mice so um so
here we want to ask sort of similar
questions but now the picture is that
the landscape is not how ingenious but
there is these sort of big patches of
environment where Emilio that all
usually call the dark allele is
beneficial and Natalie o is sort of
deleterious elsewhere okay so so there's
patches of dark rock and then surrounded
by I light substrate and these are
separated by some relatively large
distance and I guess I should have drawn
this distance as larger relative to the
size of these patches and we have mostly
the same parameters so I'll explain when
we come up um and the two things so what
we want to do is think about you know
how long do you typically have to wait
for you know a population of light mice
living on one of these patches to
acquire a mutation to the dark allele
and become adapted and then given that a
dark Leela is fixed in one of these
patches how long would you have to wait
for sort of rare migration you know past
all the owl's and so
earth to get that allele to another
patch and you know to compare those two
time scales and then then also if leo
has gone across by migration what what
should that look like okay so the first
thing is easy to to work out okay
naively right there's some number of
individuals living on this patch and so
the mutational influx is the number of
individuals times the mutation rate and
then each one of those mutations has
some probability of establishing that
you know I'm always going to approximate
by twice its selective advantage / the
variance and offspring number okay so
overall that predicts that the rate of
influx of sort of successful alleles
would be the area of the patch times the
density times the mutation rate times
the probability of establishment okay so
actually the probability of
establishment at some distance decays
exponentially as you move away from the
patch but i did some you know exact
calculations no this is distance from
the patch this is probability of
establishment of an allele given that it
arose there and what we want to do is
integrate over this blue area and we're
approximating it by a step function and
so see we do pretty good just taking
this naive approximation um you know
much better than we actually know any of
these other parameters um okay so now
let's think about migration so suppose
that dark wheels have fixed locally in
one of these patches so there will be
dark nice present outside of that patch
at sort of migration selection balance
and we know thanks to Monty and other
folks that the that the equilibrium
frequency as a function
distance looks like this it decays
exponentially with red equal to the
dispersal distance divided by the square
root of twice the you know selection
against dark my son like white
background and there's maybe a square
root correction in two dimensions um and
sort of here is what it looks like this
is from a simulation where the allele is
beneficial in this little patch in
between the double lines the color
jiggly lions are tying spices and the
black line is the average and down here
is a space cross time chunk of that
where the intensity of the red tells you
the frequency of the allele and I've
highlighted have sort of picked some of
these dark leal's that happen to get
pretty far from the original patch and
trace back their genealogy so you can
see how they you know descended from
somebody originally living in the patch
where they're adapted um okay so what
does this mean here this is sort of an
occupation density right if this tells
us that we expect there to be point one
mice per generation in this field that
what that really means is that there's
one Mouse every ten generations or
actually since they show up in sort of
families you know there's correlation
it's more something like ten miles every
hundred generations and and so this is
the process by which a new patch will
get colonized and so to understand that
process of colonization we need to we
need to understand those migrant
families if it were so um
I'm going to wave my hands quickly about
this but so in the continuum limit um
the you know that the continuum limit
the descendants of any dark ilio outside
of a patch where there where the dark
allele is beneficial looks like a
branching process so subcritical
branching process and it's branching
rate depends on how close it is to the
patch right because the closer it is the
fewer light nice adess to compete with
but it's still a branching process and
you know that's something we can compute
things we have but would still rather it
was a homogeneous branching process so
one thing we can do to get that is to
draw a bigger circle of radius R 0
around the original patch and then just
look at sort of the families of migrants
that leave r0 well they leave our zero
and might go back in but what we do is
we only consider the genealogy of
individuals that have had an ancestor
outside of our zero more recently than
they have an ancestor inside of the
original patch okay so that decomposes
the genealogy of these dark alleles into
trees that originated with migrants
moving outside of here okay and then if
we take our zero big enough you know
particularly since we're interested in
the rare ones that make it to a new
patch of fair distance away we want to
be able to approximate that by branching
processes that just have a
you know constant growth rate of 1 minus
s okay and so I'll just so here it's
sort of reiterating that that we had to
make the approximation that between
patches the sort of migrant families
that we care about are like subcritical
branching processes no relative growth
rate 1 minus SD so the chance that one
of those lives for time T is e to the
minus SD times T and as Leia was
reminding us yesterday we know what one
of those looks like conditional on
survival okay if a migrant family has
lived for a relatively long amount of
time T then it looks like a single trunk
that moves according to the spatial
notion that spits off these sub critical
branches gay in sort of for a long time
you get the spatial motion that's always
sort of surrounded by a little cluster
of close relatives with random but it's
fixed you know random size but of a
fixed distribution at least
asymptotically any questions about that
okay so that's the end so that the
approximation you want to use so then we
so then we use that picture to work out
the rate of successful migrants from one
patch to the other the chance that one
of these families hits the new patch x
the chance that it establishes given
it has okay so I think I okay yeah all
right oh sorry okay and then you know
the main missing ingredient there is
that we need to know the outflux of
these families okay because we need to
know the rate at which these families
sort of leave are not and then establish
in the new patch but it turns out we're
helped by comparing to the thing that we
already know which is the occupation
density of this process so the
occupation density so Q was the mean
frequency migration you know mean
occupation and see my gracious election
equilibrium of these families and the
migration rate is the probability of
establishment so the first thing is sort
of the integral around the boundary of
the outflux of of migrant families
multiplied by the probability that one
establishes in the new patch which is
the probability it arrives times the
chains that it establishes given that
it's there the second thing the
occupation density is the integral
around the boundary on times the outflux
of migrant families times the occupation
density here which is the probability
that it rives times the occupation
density given that it has so that tells
us that these two things are equal up to
a constant which is the ratio of the
probability of establishment given that
a family has arrived / the occupation
time here given that it as arrived the
occupation time here given is arrived
and ignoring the fact that it's some
beneficial here okay and this is sort of
this works if the separation is large
okay so we can use that to get an
expression and then we can compete some
things and here's a phase diagram
and the main thing that we get out of
this is that it depends fairly weekly
and most of the parameters except for
the distance okay there's a pretty sharp
transition between when you get sharing
of adaptations by migration and when you
don't that's relatively insensitive to
many of the parameters this these
results you would expect a little bit of
long-range migration yeah
I mean if it's recently likely that one
happens to land and Babs them were you
very much just because if you come in
just not its exponential like your
distance it's so unlikely that you look
for anything else that could happen you
know tornado spreading years yeah
biology yeah I would just pick up shots
okay right so then I won't tell you how
but you know you can work out the
distribution of the haplotype that the
migrant health that you expect the
migrant to have carried along with it
you know because that the length of the
haplotype is just determined by how many
generations that spent in transit could
because each generation is a chance to
whittle down that haplotype and we're
approximating this transit as a Brownian
motion killed Brownian motion then you
can look up explicit expressions for the
distribution of the time it takes to get
across conditional on getting there
before it's killed um can we get some
more expressions and we can plug in some
parameters to these numbers and get some
answers out which tells us so here I'm
summarizing things by the chance that a
that so given that one patch is already
adapted the chance that another patch at
distance R has adapted is sort of be
this ratio of rates and even if you put
in a pretty wide range of selection
coefficients and mutation rates you get
pretty robustly that you expect
independent adaptation over scales
larger than like tens or maybe hundreds
of kilometers and shared adaptations on
smaller scale than that ok does that
mean to say adaptation by mutation
before migration yep and and given that
it given that team patches still share
an adaptation by migration this chair
haplotype should be like 56 coisas okay
so we can compute stuff and this is
mostly Graham is fun talking to these
other people so I have some time for
questions I'm asking because I imagine
the conditioning on surviving in that
desert conditions having a relatively
large number of videos it would be a
critical branching process conditioning
on survival I guess you go away from
them
did you condition up having a few
individuals and reached very far away
you make it likely they're like a huge
number of individuals a medium distance
away yeah yeah alright subcritical
vetting process conditional on survival
looks like just a super idea has rules
what's the number of the video fear then
does it depend on the how far you away
from your vehicle yeah it's always
worried about what over to selectively
disadvantage it never gets much about
that right right so minute and that is
small and hipster Carrington yeah so big
I'm not sure to connect this clinic
carrying capacity yeah carrying capacity
I think of as a maximum density of
videos you can have locally probably
it's in the deserts more than oh it's
anyway it's all that surprising but we
have some limiting carrying capacity to
connect it to the carrying capacity I
would say so carrying capacity x s where
s is the serious effect in
in the area between the patches if that
is a much smaller than one something
different might happen because then the
contraction cross separately from 60 g
mean if like right so i think you mean
that you're from if might mice get eaten
so much in dark rocks than just about
how something it was not so bad for you
like fix in the desert but the light
Emil is better than than that are
exactly for my chance oh yeah I see
right yes right so if local dripped yeah
no that's true local driftwood cosmos
more stochasticity that you know like in
doing the branching process
approximation and probably sort of
listening that mostly out cross to the
light
don't have a good addition for women
that should change things a lot it's
actually it's even hard for Asian
particular thing else because it's a
total number of individuals alive at any
time across all the space that's limited
to not much more than one over the
selected disadvantage so at any local
area yeah I mean visit yes we're not
completely recessive and it would be
really interesting case because if it's
completely recessive and on one hand it
has a harder time establishing but on
the other hand it's a new transit better
is you're assuming it's always deployed
in its out carton right well I mean I'm
finally it's a ploy didn't
what he had sex
the other process basically invasion of
the white into the black more like areas
to your estimation making sense that way
or is it really just the other way that
you can base us mates because you have
the distance and you have probabilities
the and probabilities of moving from one
patch to the other path versus their way
around the invasion self counted but you
don't really need see anything or you
don't really get it but what do you want
to know about the light ones coming into
the dark apps yet what do you want to
know about it just in terms of like the
frequencies and if you base your
estimates on that event rather than your
story was that you all about black ones
Miami I over in the next back black
passion so considering that the white
ones has been going to black practice as
well um but what we're interested in is
how long certain like are you thinking
of the case where the dark my Spurs
re-establish the dark gives the incest
when you're reading through the other
things like a tomato slices the mysore
alone
my first the mice living in tithing
x
ok
good I think actually we have one more
copy